okay so like with with most things in
the world and in politics the reality is
rarely completely black and white
although in many cases it's a pretty
dark shade of gray and along those lines
today we have to talk about the talking
points that are spreading about
undemocratically stealing the nomination
from Bernie Sanders compared to actually
building consensus within the Democratic
Party now as you all know by now there's
no doubt that the Democratic
establishment does not want Bernie
Sanders to be the Democratic
presidential nominee just like was the
case in 2016 now you don't have to
support Bernie Sanders - in order to
believe that you would have to be quite
naive at this point to deny that you
know everything from the MSNBC coverage
in the aftermath of Bernie's win in
Nevada to the DNC considering reeling
the super-delegates to vote on round one
at the convention all of this stuff is
evidence that the Democratic
establishment doesn't want Bernie to be
the nominee okay now there are a couple
of ways that Bernie could end up with
more pledged delegates than anybody else
but not end up with the nomination not
all of those scenarios are equally
problematic in the context of how
nominations are decided now listen I
know there are people who are going to
see this video and they're gonna dislike
it and say David's advocating for this
that the I'm not doing anything other
than informing my audience about how
this works and allowing people to have
the information to decide for themselves
when something is or is not undemocratic
now this is really important because
like 80% of the commentaries I'm seeing
from the left about how Bernie may have
the nomination denied are accurate 80
percent are accurate there's 20 percent
that are missing the mark and what I
want to do is distinguish between the
two scenarios that are the most likely
so that we can all be on the same page
if you don't like that if you want to
punish me and you want to dislike this
video on YouTube or write me a mean
letter go ahead but I'm gonna do the
show the way I think the show should be
done and informing people about this is
really important so let's look first at
the cartoonish obvious and disgusting
way that Bernie could have more
delegates than anybody else
and end up not being the nominee if
Bernie Sanders gets a plurality of
pledged delegates in the primaries and
then there's a first round of voting at
the DNC and nobody gets to 50% plus one
delegates then they do a second round of
voting with super-delegates and Bernie
could lose this would not be Bernie
losing because there was consensus built
between the delegates of different
candidates this would simply be a
completely undemocratic process a
mirroring of the 2016 scenario except
with super-delegates voting in the
second round instead of in the first it
would be completely shameful I'm against
the inclusion and use of super-delegates
altogether it's undemocratic it's an
establishment centrist perversion of
what should be a democratic process
there is also another scenario that
could deny Bernie Sanders the nomination
and we may not like the outcome but it
does reflect a sort of consensus
building that is often a requirement of
the political system working correctly
even if we don't like the outcome I will
lay it out for you imagine that Bernie
Sanders has a plurality of the delegates
but not a majority which seems quite
likely at this point although things
could shift and Bernie could end up with
a majority let's imagine Bernie has
thirty five percent of the delegates
heading into the convention it is
completely conceivable that in advance
of that first vote at the DNC
super-delegates aren't involved three
centrist candidates might combine their
delegates and get to fifty percent plus
one it would be a negotiation between
the candidates and their supporters
imagine let's make it really specific
imagine that going into the convention
now we'll use other numbers
Bernie has Bernie has twenty-eight
percent of the delegates Pete Budaj has
21 percent and Joe Biden has 16 percent
and Amy Klobuchar has 14 percent I
believe that when you vote for a
candidate in the primary you are voting
for their decision-making ability in
total and if you vote Amy and she
decides at the convention my policies
are more likely to be enacted by Biden
than by Bernie and she says hey Amy
delegates go and vote for Biden
and if the Buddha judged people do the
same thing they could negotiate for all
of those delegates to support Joe Biden
and Biden would get 50% plus one Bernie
had more delegates than any one other
candidate but of course most of the
delegates were for other candidates and
you could see that negotiation take
place it's not super-delegates coming in
from above and undemocratically handing
the nomination to someone now if you
don't like that you can argue there
should be no such negotiations possible
in advance of that first round of voting
but the problem is in a field where
imagine you have 15 or 18 candidates the
candidate with a plurality might only
have nine 10 11 12 percent of the vote
in that case do we want a system that
says even with eleven percent of the
vote if it's a plurality that candidate
must be the nominee
when 89 percent voted for somebody else
it doesn't sound completely right to me
even if it leads to an outcome that is
not the one I want so now let me be
absolutely crystal clear I'm voting for
Bernie Sanders in the primary I believe
super-delegates should not decide the
nomination but we need to disaggregate
the two scenarios imagine it going a
different way
imagine Bernie gets his thirty seven
percent of the delegates okay going into
the convention and Elizabeth Warren has
14 percent we know if Bernie doesn't get
that first ballot nomination on the
second round super-delegates give it to
somebody else
Elizabeth Warren could direct her
delegates her 14 percent to vote for
Bernie 37 plus 14 is 51 and that gets
Bernie to the nomination on the first
round it's a progressive consensus
building movement it's not practically
speaking different than the delegates of
to three or four centrist candidates
doing the same thing we may not like the
system in which case we should lobby for
it to be changed but that scenario is
not the authoritarian undemocratic
nightmare of super-delegates coming in
and simply saying nothing there's no
negotiations no consensus building the
super-delegates just vote for Biden or
for Budaj or whatever let's maintain
credibility and
consistency let's acknowledge that these
are two different scenarios and let's
work to ensure that working within that
no superdelegates the first process
there that that I mentioned is the
undemocratic super delegate one we're
against that but let's work knowing that
the second scenario could happen to
build consensus and to do what needs to
be done for the candidate we want to be
the nominee if you think that this is a
distinction without a difference I
disagree with you and I want to hear
from you tell me what's wrong with my
analysis privacy comm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's of
service i've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman